hello everyone grant here so I'd like to
talk to you today about the various
functions of money functions of money
now money of course is something that we
all use every day and we kind of have a
general feel for what it is but it's
interesting to step back and actually
contemplate what is money what gives it
its value what is it that we use it for
why is it that you can use some things
for money throughout history you know
people have used not just gold and
silver but things like salt or
cigarettes as money and why other things
can't be used and economists generally
divide the functions of money the things
that it does for us into three different
categories and sometimes people will add
a fourth in there I won't get to that in
this video I'll talk about it in a
different one but there's kind of three
main ones that people usually talk about
so if you were an economist just kind of
philosophizing about what the functions
of money are you might start by thinking
well what does the world look like
without money like for example let's say
that you were a lawyer and you you know
you provide legal counsel to people and
this is the service that you provide and
this is the way that you add value to
the economy and let's say it's the case
that you your refurnishing and you want
a chair right you want to go out to the
world and you want to buy a chair well
what that would require is that you find
someone who happens to produce chairs
you find some person out there and his
way of adding value to society is to
produce chairs and this is what he does
and he has specialized at it and he's
very good now the issue here because
money doesn't exist
you basically have to trade with him you
have to barter in some way and this is
what's called a barter economy and in
order to do that given that you've
specialized in laws the thing that you
provide and add value with you kind of
have to hope that he wants legal
services that he happens to be in a
situation where he wants the thing that
you provide which in this case is legal
services and if that was true if you had
that good fortune then you would be able
to trade some legal services over to him
and he would trade you some number of
chairs and all would be well but of
course this is this feels kind of rare
especially given how specialized you are
and this idea where you want something
and he wants something and does line up
with each other actually has a name this
is called the double coincidence of
wants double coincidence and it's worth
writing down because people kind of
reference this when we're talking about
barter economies of want and buy barter
economy I just mean you know this kind
of setup but scaled up to the scale of
society where everybody's trading based
on their specialty and what someone else
needs and of course in a world of money
this seems absurd because in reality
what you do is you would be over here
and sure you would provide your legal
services you would kind of provide legal
services to someone as your way of
adding value but it would be to just
anyone who wants it not not based on
what they produce and in response in
exchange for that they give you cash
they just give you you know money
something you can then use that
everybody accepts for whatever it is
that you want so in this case you know
if you want a chair then you bring it
over to the guy who produces chairs and
that's what he gives you you know a
chair and insofar as money serves this
function where it is kind of the
universal thing to trade it's called a
medium medium of exchange of exchange
and what that means is anytime that you
want to exchange for something this is
the common thing of value that you use
to actually trade with the world but
that's not the only thing money does
that's a really big part that kind of
allows the entire economy to exist and
it allows you to specialize in something
like legal services but what else does
money do what else would be harder to do
in a world without money let's say you
produced as a lawyer you know producing
legal services a little bit more than
you actually want it to consume and
you're hoping to kind of save up some
value so that maybe later on you can buy
a house or you can you know pay for your
kids education or something like that
you want to actually start storing value
and saving it up well in this barter
economy you would have to find something
since money doesn't exist you would have
to find something of value and start
storing that maybe you know chairs might
hold their value so you're hoping to
store them or maybe you have to buy land
or something that you think will store
it but there's not kind of a good de
facto medium that you can do it for so
in this sense since that's something
that we usually do with money it's also
called a good store of value so this is
considered kind of a second use of money
store of value distinct from medium of
exchange because the idea of needing
something to trade
is pretty different from wanting to kind
of save value and for this third
function a think back to this case where
you're hoping to barter legal services
for chairs I mean once you start getting
into the specifics you can start asking
the question well actually how many
hours right like how many hours of legal
services corresponds to one chair and if
you want to buy something different you
know you're going grocery shopping how
many hours of legal services corresponds
to buying one Apple and similarly the
chair guy he has to go off and every
time he's going to buy an apple he has
to think how many chairs correspond to
an apple and trying to relate values
like this so it's getting really
complicated unless you just have some
kind of actual unit to deal with
something that you can use to actually
measure value of everything like a
yardstick for value and of course in the
real economy we just give everything at
a dollar value or a URL value or a peso
value depending on where you are but you
give it a value that corresponds to the
currency to the money that you're
dealing with so people will say that
money serves as a unit of value a unit
of value and basically that means that
it gives you the starting number it
gives you the meaning of the number one
so that you can say well if this is
worth $1 then what is worth $3 or maybe
an hour of this lawyers time is worth
$100 in one of these chairs is worth $50
and you can start actually comparing the
values of various different goods that
way and actually think this is this is a
pretty interesting one this is the kind
of thing that would be easy to under
appreciated it is to have something like
this and in the next video or two I'm
going to talk about a certain historical
case of hyperinflation in Brazil where
basically what happens is money loses
some of these functions and you can see
just how much a society actually breaks
down if what is supposed to be money
stops serving these functions so with
that I will see you next video